joe jorgensen is the libertarian party's
nominee for president
in 2020 and the only candidate on the
ballot in
all 50 states other than donald trump
and joe biden
a recent npr poll showed her pulling 5
nationally which could cover the spread
between the president and his challenger
according to a chorus of pundits and
partisans though voting for a third
party candidate is a waste
because it doesn't change the high
stakes battle to either
toss out or keep in office donald trump
in 2021
this is not the time to withhold our
votes
in protests or play games with
candidates who have no
chance of winning jorgensen a 63 year
old clemson psychology lecturer is
running out a blend of standard small
government rhetoric discussed with
career politicians optimism about young
people
and of course the occasional craziness
that we all expect from third party
nominees
i am running for president because
government is too big
too bossy too nosy too intrusive but the
worst part
is they usually end up hurting the very
people they're trying to help
she says that most of her followers are
either independents or first-time voters
and that the real mistake would be to
vote for trump or biden
particularly in parts of the country
where a principled vote
is unlikely to impact the final outcome
i would say if you're in a solidly red
state like i'm
in if you don't like what donald trump
has been doing
if you don't like the bigger government
he's given you then voting for him
is a wasted vote and to democrats
especially democrats
in california and new york don't vote
for joe biden
vote for what you really want jorgensen
who ran as the lp's vice presidential
nominee back in 1996
wants to bring all the troops home cut
the size of government in half
legalize drugs and in our interview
suggested replacing ruth bader ginsburg
on the supreme court with someone like
82 year old
alan dershowitz though she later
recanted on social media because of his
statements
that torture may sometimes be acceptable
his opposition to gun rights and what
she called
unresolved questions about his
association with jeffrey epstein
jorgensen says that republicans have
failed to live up to their promises of
fiscal discipline
a lot of people don't realize that
government grew year after year after
year for
eight straight years with reagan people
keep saying oh look at donald trump we
got tax cuts
well yeah but he increased spending so
the bill is
eventually going to come due he came in
saying i'm a businessman i know how to
balance the budget i know how to cut
spending
and he didn't do that and not only did
he not cut spending
he increased spending now we've got a
bigger deficit bigger debt
whether you're talking education health
care uh retirement
it all boils down to are you in control
of your dollars
biden says jorgensen has shamelessly
pandered to voters for nearly
50 years people wanted to hear him say
i'm tough on crime so he said i'm tough
on crime
and now they want to hear something else
so something he doesn't have a rudder he
doesn't have
something that's guiding him that's true
not only about
biden but pretty much any democrat out
there
young people are shocked to hear that
both hillary clinton
and barack obama were against gay
marriage
just back in 2012 that was only eight
years ago
speaking of young people jorgensen is
big on gen z
arguing that young americans are less
about cancer culture and being woke
and more about being laissez-faire they
go well why shouldn't you be able to own
a gun why
shouldn't two people the same sex get
married you can drink bread wine why
can't you smoke marijuana so
that overall they have a very
libertarian underpinning as far as their
kind of
live and let live libertarian philosophy
so that's
excellent news if i could sit around the
kitchen table of every american family
in this country i would win by a
landslide
[Music]